and speaking of your space let's talk
surfaces the international surface event
is underway and cola manufacturing the
sponsors of this segment is excited to
make their debut there and also in town
here's what they're mixing up in Vegas
welcome to Cola manufacturing where the
foundation is flooring and family at
Coley manufacture what we do here is we
make SPC trademarked by Daniel Mitchell
we produce flooring from powder and I
like to describe it like a cake mix
there's all these ingredients that go in
and there's a beginning and it's a
circle and it goes all the way around
until we get this lovely panel or lovely
flooring Coley actually means easy we
started the factory in the very
beginning of covid there was nothing
easy about this but we are now ready to
take it to Market we're going to be at
the surfaces show and now it's time for
us to shine here in Vegas and if you
can't catch colay and Dan's neon tank
collection at surfaces this week you can
spot their work in major properties
around town the majority of the places
that we actually put the product is
going to be in the casinos hotels
a lot multifamily we do a lot of that we
also run a hospital here in Las Vegas
where we get it into the actual units of
the uh the rooms and then all the
corridors going around in in that we
also
um that's pretty much what we do in the
apartments and also the hotels colay
started as an International import
company but they're proud to say their
very own product is 100 made in the USA
we have the import company over in
California which we've been doing you
know for 12 years since 2010
um but that is more the commercial
product line here here we're going uh
for the show here this is a dealer show
so we're actually going after the dealer
Market uh something brand new we have
never advertised we've never done
anything out there in the market that's
the first time to actually take and
showcase what it is that we can make
here and it's made right here all of it
from the beginning all the way through
all the way through in their state of
the the Art Factory we are here at the
SPC Factory we are happy to be in Las
Vegas Nevada so there's a few few
different processes that go into making
SPC and what that breaks down to a stone
plastic composite and there's different
additives and Limestone mixed together
with TDC powder that make our standard
uh platforms here that we print on we
have multiple platforms that we utilize
whether it's shower panels wall panels
countertops flooring what we like to
focus on here and drive towards is a
proprietary system that we call our
Titan series coating now what that is is
it's ceramic it's a ceramic coating
built in different chemistry platforms
that we've mastered and broken down to
and that gives it a very very different
scratch appeal you can think of you know
going home and moving your furniture
you're just pulling you get that scratch
in your wear layer with our standard
proprietary system that we have in our
coating you can scratch and you can
literally wipe it off with your hand at
least no residue or no scratching you
know I had to put that to the test
okay I see a little scratch go ahead and
wipe that with your hand you can see
that that wipes right off okay this is
the star of the show I'm showering under
the sea it's a lot it's a wild it's a
wild crazy concept but it's something
we're so happy happy to uh to Showcase
here at the services event one thing
that we're gonna do is Showcase the
digital printing capabilities that we
can do and I think we really set it off
with this one yeah I'm gonna go ahead
and order a jungle theme I got you we're
going to prioritize that today
well cool thank you Cole manufacturing
for sponsoring that segment you can find
them over in North Las Vegas for more
information call
702-802-0351 or visit
colemanufacturing.com and they're having
an inventory below out sale right now
during the international surface event
and that ends tomorrow